Well,
there are a lot of flaws in the judicial
system.
I think we could probably do with that.
Elections have judges,
uh,
that creates problems.
Um,
I think that we could do a lot more to
educate the judiciary in terms of a
scientific evidence.
We have a real problem there.
It's a increasingly scientific evidence
is becoming important in a whole host of
cases,
not just criminal cases.
Um,
and it's important that,
uh,
we have a certain level of scientific
literacy,
uh,
in the judiciary,
much less among lawyers.
Uh,
uh,
so I think those are two problems.
Um,
you know,
a psych at all of our politics,
uh,
money can make a real difference in
corrupting the process of judicial
elections.
So we've,
a,
John Grisham has written a wonderful
book about this called the appeal.
It's very quick reading,
but it's a very troubling,
there've been a number of judicial
elections for highest appellate courts
in this country where moneyed interests
have been able to basically go after
certain judges.
They're really interested,
uh,
in their,
you know,
corporate cases,
uh,
or maybe some tort reform case,
but they're able to make some kind of
ruling in a criminal case or something
else.
Uh,
uh,
look,
very scary to the electorate.
And,
uh,
they,
all of a sudden outside money comes into
estate in an enormous amount.
And,
uh,
some campaign is run and judges are
defeated.
Happened to a fabulous judge in
Wisconsin.
Um,
uh,
it's happened all across the country and
the most famous instances,
one that the United States Supreme Court
looked into in West Virginia involving
the Massey Coal Company.
And that was the coal company where we
had that terrible accident in the minds
recently,
um,
where,
uh,
the head of that coal company,
I'm a put an enormous amount of money
into the judicial election for the West
Chester,
West Virginia Supreme Court.
Um,
and then the judge who was the
beneficiary of this,
uh,
you know,
sat on the case and,
uh,
the United States Supreme Court to
actually ruled in this,
uh,
case that,
that had,
uh,
an appearance of impropriety.
Uh,
we know when we see it.
And,
uh,
um,
reversed the decision in that case.
So,
um,
that's a remanded it for
reconsideration.
That's a very,
very extreme example,
but unfortunately I think a lot of that
is going around the country and that,
that,
uh,
I know that a Sandra Day O'connor,
for example,
feels very,
very strongly about
judicial elections being a real problem.
And there's probably a lot of different
kinds of merit systems,
uh,
that should be considered across the
country.